Salut la team Mentalo !
Il y a quelques jours, je vais ai dit sur YouTube que j'allais refaire une true story et aussi une mentalisation par Skype.
J'ai lu vos commentaires, je vous écoute, je commence par la true story.
Alors c'est une histoire qui ne m'est pas arrivée tout seul, ça m'est arrivé avec mon pote Philippe Roche,
vous savez mon pote imitateur qui est déjà passé deux fois en vidéo.
Je sais qui en a qui sont abonnés à sa chaine.
Voilà, ça s'est passé avec lui.
En 2008, on était en Ukraine, on avait fait trois villes en Ukraine.
Et on était à bord d'un bateau, donc on faisait toute la cote: Odessa, Yalta, Sébastopol.
Pour traverser ensuite la mer noire et aller à Istanbul.
On est arrivé à quai, à Odessa, c'était la première ville.
On est descendus. Il y avait un grand escalier quand tu descends du port d'Odessa avec une statue de Richelieu en haut.
Et là, on a été frappé par deux choses.
La première chose, c'est qu'on entend souvent dans les bars de la variété française.
Alors pas forcément la variété actuelle, même si on entendait du Zaz ou des trucs comme ça...mais beaucoup d'Edith Piaf, d'Aznavour...
Et la deuxième chose qui nous a frappé, c'est que les filles étaient vraiment sublimes !
Les filles, et les femmes sont très belles à Odessa.
Il y a une légende qui dit qu'il y a les plus belles femmes du monde à Odessa... Bah c'est pas complètement faux !
Comme on était un samedi, on a eu la chance d'assister à un mariage, parce qu'apparemment c'est le samedi là-bas.
C'est des mariages, c'est juste ouf ! C'est complètement incroyable.
Il y a les limousines, il y a tout, même si ils n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent, ils rendent la chose sublime.
Et les filles, il faut savoir qu'elles se marient très très jeunes là-bas. Vers 20 ans elles se marient.
Ce qui explique aussi qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de divorces.
Je pense quand meme que c'est lié.
Bref ! Ce n'est pas vraiment le propos.
On part dans notre quête habituelle avec Philippe, c'est-à-dire qu'à chaque fois qu'on touchait terre, au bout de quelques jours de mer,
notre mission c'est de trouver un bar pas trop cher, donc pas trop touristique, un vrai bar local, et où il y a si possible, le Wi-Fi gratuit.
C'est meme très important en fait le Wi-Fi !
Pour ça on s'enfonce toujours dans les villes, dans les petites ruelles, pour trouver vraiment les endroits locaux.
Et des fois c'est des endroits un peu improbables.
Et là, à l'étage d'un bâtiment, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un bâtiment avec des entrées, il y a un escalier et avec une petite terrasse en haut.
On voit un bar qui à l'air hyper sympa, hyper cosy.
Modeste, mais très bien décoré à l'intérieur.
C'est plutôt cool. On décide d'aller se poser là-bas, on monte, on s'assied, tout se passe bien !
La serveuse arrive, on passe notre commande. En Ukraine c'est assez facile de parler, parce qu'ils parlent anglais, ukrainien et russe. En général ils maitrisent ces trois langues là, assez facilement.
Voire trois ou quatre langues.
Là c'était un petit peu différent, la serveuse ne parlait pas anglais.
Mais bon, quand on veut quelque chose on arrive toujours à se débrouiller, à se faire comprendre. J'ai des notions de russe, Philippe avait des petites notions en ukrainiens...
On se débrouille.
On commande nos boissons, on sort les ordis portables, on se connecte, la serveuse revient avec les boissons pour nous servir, et là il y a Philippe qui lâche devant elle, juste à coté d'elle:
"Elle a de ces yeux put*** !"
Il dit cette phrase la.
"Elle a de ces yeux put***."
Parce Philippe il est marseillais. Donc c'est-à-dire que "put***" c'est un mot de ponctuation chez eux, c'est comme si on mettait un point, ou une virgule, ou un point d'exclamation.
Il sort le "put***" comme ça quoi ! [imite l'accent marseillais]
Et là, je vois un changement d'ambiance direct dans la salle...
On est pas nombreux, on est les seuls vrais clients. Le reste ça doit être les copains du patron, je pense, ou alors des clients très habitués.
Tout se crispe un peu... Tu sais cette tendance qui devient un petit de...
Qu'est-ce que... Qu'est-ce qu'on fout là..., déjà...?
Alors t'as le patron qui n'était pas très fun, c'était plutôt une armoire qui était au niveau du contoir. Lui, il fait la gueule direct, ça commence à se crisper là.
La serveuse, ça ne va plus du tout non plus.
Je vois un peu tous les signes de la colère sur tout le monde.
En plus on avait parlé bien fort.
Et là je comprends, qu'il y a un mot commun qu'on comprend en français, que l'on peut utiliser là-bas et qui est compris aussi,
c'est le mot "put***".
Sauf qu'eux ils ne connaissent qu'une seule signification à ce mot. C'est le sens propre littéral de ce mot.
Le mot qu'on va dire maintenant...
pour éviter que je le dise tout au long de la vidéo... le mot interdit !
Et là mon gars quand t'es perdu dans le fin fond d'Odessa et qu'il se passe ça et que tu sais que tu es dans une petite ruelle chelou, pas mal famée mais pas terrible non plus...
Tu te dis, il va quand même falloir la jouer serrer...
Quand tu as tout le bar là, tous les copains du patron qui te regardent avec un œil mauvais, bon... tu as tendance à réfléchir encore plus vite.
Je comprends le truc en deux secondes. J'explique très rapidement à Philippe ce qui est en train de se passer.
Et je lui dit: "Mon Philou... (parce que oui, je l'appelle Philou !) j'ai une idée !"
À partir de ce moment là, on a fait nous comme si on ne comprenait pas ce qui était en train de se passer, comme si on avait rien senti.
On a continué à parler, en parlant toujours fort, sauf qu'on avait comme règle de mettre "put***"...
Mais j'ai dit le mot interdit. [rires]
Sauf que l'on avait comme règle de mettre le mot interdit dans chaque phrase, tout le temps.
C'est-à-dire: "Tu peux me passer le sel put*** pour que je selle mes frites put*** ?"
On le mettait tout le temps.
Et ça, c'était juste pour déstabiliser tout le monde et qu'il l'entende à tout bout de champ.
Et ça a commencé à marcher.
J'ai vu que le patron il nous regardait là, plus énervé mais d'un œil très bizarre donc, toute la tension était redescendue.
Et ça c'est déjà mieux que de passer pour deux cibles.
Pour finir le truc, j'ai sorti un jeu de cartes, j'ai toujours un jeu de cartes avec moi quand on se déplace.
Et j'ai fait un ou deux tours de magie, je ne me souviens plus...
Ah si ! Deux.
J'ai fait un premier tour, je lui ai fait un deuxième. Et c'est au deuxième tour de magie que j'ai vu que le patron et la serveuse et tout le monde était en train de nous regarder.
Et je leur ai fait signe qu'ils pouvaient venir, qu'ils pouvaient se rapporcher. Avec un grand sourire.
Je me suis mis à leur faire des tours de magie, des tours de cartes.
Alors on se débrouillait plus ou moins pour se comprendre, tout en prenant soin de continuer à placer le mot interdit très régulièrement dans mes phrases quand je parlais français.
La finalité de cette histoire elle est drôle, parce qu'on avait réussi à comprendre qu'on avait créer une tension,
on a réussi à comprendre pourquoi on a réussi à retourner ça dans un autre sens.
Puisqu'à la fin, on se marrait tous ensemble, et qu'au moment de partir, la dernière tournée, la patron nous la offerte
On a pris deux tournées et la deuxième on ne la pas payée, il nous en a fait cadeau.
C'était pas gagné au moment où Philippe à dit qu'elle avait des super beaux yeux put*** ! [imite l'accent marseillais]
Voilà les Mentalos ! J'espère que cette tranche de vie vous aura plu.
Si vous en voulez d'autres, likez la vidéo.
On va dire, je vais garder un œil sur la vidéo, et le jour où celle-ci elle dépassera les 3000 pouces, j'en ferai une autre.
Comme ça, ce ne sera pas trop souvent, pas trop régulier, et ça nous fera un compteur.
Et puis racontez moi dans les commentaires les moments un peu tendus comme ça que vous avez vécu, les situations qui sont un petit peu à risque et que vous avez réussi à retourner, c'est toujours marrant de lire ça.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner également en cliquant ici.
Et rendez-vous demain matin à 11H, le samedi c'est 11H.
Ciao !
[musique]
Je joue mon spectacle en tournée toute l'année. Pour connaître les villes, passez faire un tour sur mon site Internet. Il y a le lien dans le descriptif !